[Music]
all right right behind the dipstick
seems to be the hot spot I think would
give it about 10-15 miles and it should
be perfectly cooked
thirty minutes of cooking time fun hot
dog here guys who wants a hot dog there
you go buddy
guys want s'mores all right we got the
s'mores sitting on the engine block well
let that sit for about ten minutes
s'more mmm there you go not a bad engine
blocks more hmm if you liked this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]